le sida ce serait sur le point d'être
vaincus le sida c'est cette maladie qui
entraîne l'effondrement du système
immunitaire et contre laquelle les
médecins étaient jusqu'à présent désarmé
une maladie qui touche essentiellement
les homosexuels est certes un hémophile
un véritable fléau qui a coûté la vie à
plus de 1700 personnes aux états unis
depuis les années 80 les chercheurs
français de l'institut pasteur était
déjà parvenue à isoler un virus tenu
pour responsable de cette terrible
maladie
et aujourd'hui ce sont les américains
qui sont parvenus à un résultat
identique c'est du moins ce qu'a annoncé
la nuit dernière le secrétaire d'état
américain à la santé alors les deux
virus se sont pas tout à fait semblable
mais cette nouvelle découverte confirme
que l'on est sur le point de connaître
avec précision les causes de la maladie
les américains ont dépensé en recherche
75 millions de dollars depuis
l'apparition du sida et l'on peut penser
qu'un vaccin sera mis au point dans les
deux ans qui viennent
les explications de martin à la réunion
4000 cas aux états unis 300 cas en
europe le sida une maladie que craignent
avant tout les homosexuels les
toxicomanes les hémophiles une maladie
effroyable qui supprime les défenses du
malade souvent jusqu'au cancer parfois
jusqu'à la mort et dont depuis quatre
ans on recherchait activement la cause
sans la trouver
jusqu'à hier soir secrétaire d'état à la
santé des états unis margaret chan clare
annoncé la nouvelle
une équipe américaine pense avoir isolé
un virus responsable du sida un virus
qui ressemble étrangement à celui cas
isolé voici un an
une équipe de l'institut pasteur à
laquelle l'amérique rend hommage
aujourd'hui
de fait les docteurs montagne et sherman
barré sinoussi ont découvert l'an passé
que le sang des malades présentant les
signes précurseurs de sida au niveau des
ganglions contient presque toujours un
virus ce qui semble nouveau c'est que le
virus américains identifiés cette
semaine aux états unis et le virus
français découvert voici un an sont
vraisemblablement un seul et même virus
si cela se confirme les progrès dans la
lutte contre la maladie pourront
maintenant aller très vite en
coopération entre les états unis et
l'institut pasteur
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on va
pouvoir faire des éléments de diagnostic
ans
rechercher si des personnes sont
porteurs ou non de ce virus deuxièmement
on va pouvoir rechercher dans les
substituts du sang par exemple si le
virus est présent ou pas c'est à dire
éviter tout ce qui s'est passé
maintenant pour les cas de sida chez les
hémophiles par exemple bouger les
politiques ont fusé ensuite la
prévention c'est bien quand on connaît l
la cause quand on a mené un virus et
bien on va préparer un vaccin donc
préparer un vaccin
ça veut dire commencer à inactiver et
russe et a recherché le pouvoir
protecteur facial et lino clessé des
animaux nous avons déjà essayé d
d'inoculer le là puisque nous l'appelons
le lavant les montagnes et françoise
barré mais on inocule et ce virus à des
chimpanzés à la des animaux les singes
et nous attendons les résultats vous
savez comme moi que la période
d'incubation du sida chez l'homme et
d'une moyenne de 5 ans donc il faut
attendre pour voir apparaître les
premiers ici chez ces animaux donc
encore bien des recherches en
perspective mais cette fois il semble
qu'on voit le bout du tunnel